ورحب بكم مشاهدين على قناه الجزيره اذا
هذه الاخبار العاجله التي تريدنا اذا من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث افادت اذا اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش يشن هجوما على
قطاع غزه وهو الهجوم الاول منذ عمليه
الفجره الاخيره والهجوم اذا حسب اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي ياتي ردا على اطلاقه نار
من قطاع غزه
كما قالت اذا المصادر الاسرائيليه لانها
هجمات اسرائيليه عده
تتم على مواقع في شمال وجنوب ووسط قطاع
غزه في هذه اللحظات
وكمان نشاهد اذا في هذه الصور التي تصلنا
منه هناك
وقد افادت الى المصادر الى الجزيره ان
مضادات ارضيه تابعه للفصائل الفلسطينيه
اطلقت اتجاهها طائرات الاحتلال الشمالي
قطاع غزه
الاسرائيلي بين الجيش الهجوم على القطاعه
في اول هجوم منذ عمليه الفجر في شهر اغسطس
الماضي على قطاع غزه
مشاهدينا في هذه الصور تداعيات هذا القصف
هذه الصور اذا اوضح
توثق اذا هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه على مناطق معينه في
القطاع
من كل الجوانب
الجيش اذانا الاسرائيلي الذي كان قد اعلن
امس الخميس اعتراض منظومه القبه الحديديه
صاروخا اطلق اذا للمره الاولى منذ قرابه
ثلاثه اشهر اتجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
في غلاف القطعه
[موسيقى]
وقبل اعلان الى رصد اطلاق الصاروخ من
القطاع الجيش قال انه تم
تفعيل صافرات اذا الانذار في عدد من
المستوطنات قرب الحدود مع غزه جنوبي اذن